was your first experience playing in
this Nebraska Colorado rivalry I know
your coach had told you all week it was
personal were you guys able to really
buy into this rivalry and what did it
feel like out there it was extremely
personal we go out there warm up you got
the head coach put out a team trying to
stand in the middle of the buff like
it's okay like some couple players do it
it's fine you know like just enjoy the
scenery but when you got the whole team
trying to disrespect it and I'm not you
know I'm not going for that at all so I
went in there and disrupted it so they
knew I've ripped like nah this the
Buffaloes me mean a lot to me and
personally that's what I was saying
pregame and that's when I knew it was
just extreme disrespect
and that's why it was the coach the
coast
said a lot of things about my pops about
the program but now that he want to act
nice I don't I don't I don't respect
that because you hating on another man
you shouldn't do that so it was just all
respect was going for them in their
program
now I like playing against their DC I
like playing against them but respect
level it ain't it ain't there because
you disrespected us first
we did our homework and seen why he
meant that why he said that but yeah it
was a lot of disrespect going on I mean
pregame we was in the middle holding up
they pointing the ball into our almost
hit our head coach in the head so it's
like yeah it's personal after that
we wanted to run a score for real we
ain't doing what really supposed to do